[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily a man
accused of killing his parents stands
trial as jurors are selected in the
wisconsin murder case of chandler
holders and after more than 5 million
petition signatures an uproar about a
truck driver's 110 year sentence the
colorado governor steps in to help rahel
aguilera moderates plus a jury weighs
the fate of a former ceo in california
as the liberations resume in the fraud
case for elizabeth holmes then later
jury selection for deante rosales gets
pushed back a day as the 27 year old is
retried in a 2014 murder long crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin wisconsin murder case of chandler
halderson gets underway as jury
selection begins halderson is accused of
killing and dismembering his parents in
july of last year the 23 year old faces
multiple charges including first degree
intentional homicide mutilating a corpse
hiding in corpse and lying to police in
july of last year halderson told
investigators and local tv stations that
his parents went missing after leaving
for a july 4th weekend trip days later
he was arrested his after his father's
torso was found on property belonging to
his girlfriend's family then his
mother's legs were found in a nearby
county
on monday jury selection for the trial
began in madison wisconsin that's where
law and crime daily reporter sierra
gillespie joins us now live with the
latest developments with potential
jurors
brian temperatures outside are freezing
here in the capital city but inside the
dane county courthouse jury selection is
heating up in the state of wisconsin
versus chandler halderson now the
biggest hurdle that defense attorneys
and prosecutors are running into is the
familiarity with the case and that many
potential jurors have seen tv station
reports or read articles about this
highly publicized case here so far today
a couple of potential jurors have
already been dismissed saying they are
too close to the case some even saying
they believe that halderson is guilty
and that their opinions could not be
swayed with any amount of evidence now
all this as the defendant chandler
halderson himself listens on as many
potential jurors point the finger and
say he is guilty but halderson's
response has been pretty stoic he pretty
much just blinks in response
occasionally he writes on a legal pad in
front of him or takes a sip of water but
there isn't much response or even much
conversation with his defense attorneys
now on the opposite side of things we
have heard from some other potential
jurors who say that while they're
familiar with the case they believe that
the media coverage here in madison
wisconsin has been swayed and slanted
against halderson saying he's guilty
before we've even gotten to opening
statements now so far today about a
dozen potential jurors have been
dismissed for a variety of reasons in
the end there will be 12 that are chosen
with six alternates and so far majority
of the demographic we've seen is about a
lot of white people who are mostly age
30 and up so jury selection is still
underway here and opening statements are
expected to begin tomorrow brian
thank you sierra joining us today is
criminal defense attorney bernardo
villalona and terry austin bernard it's
an understatement to say this case is an
uphill battle for the defense so what
kind of juror are they looking for to
get anything but a guilty verdict
so brian when you when you have a case
like this where there's so much evidence
you have the body that's recovered as
well as the statements that were
provided by the defendant it really
doesn't matter because you have so much
strong evidence you have the dna you
have physical evidence and you have the
statement so any juror would be able to
convict based on the evidence presented
the only thing you really need to ask of
these jurors are you willing can you
follow the judge's instruction if i
prove my case beyond a reasonable doubt
it's will you find him guilty that's it
so
terry um
bernardo outlined many of the strong
evidence in this case but what's the
smoking gun in this case what's the
strongest fact that gets the prosecution
to the verdict they're looking for
where do we even begin brian there are
so many smoking guns this may not seem
to sound like it's a smoking gun but to
me the fact that he misled the
authorities right then and there i think
you have to look at the fact that he is
not credible that he's hiding something
obviously those google searches were
very serious because he was looking for
bodies found that to me is indicating
that he has some consciousness of guilt
then the authorities went to the home
and sections of the floor and the wall
were missing that's quite odd what does
that mean was there blood on the floor
was he trying to cover something up and
then obviously the fact that they found
the remains of both his parents at
different places and his phone was
connected to where the remains were
found so there are so many smoking guns
here i don't think he's going to get out
of it as bernard says they just have to
look at the facts and find him guilty
the question is how long will it take
them to get to that verdict now sierra
what can we expect moving forward as
opening stamens looms in the coming days
yeah so brian first we have to find that
jury and then the highly anticipated
opening statements the biggest question
mark we have right now is will halderson
take the stand in his own defense and
actually just moments ago some potential
jurors were dismissed because they said
that if halderson did not take the stand
they would automatically find him guilty
and there was nothing that could sway
that so here the biggest question mark
is will halderson take the stand and
we're all eagerly waiting to see what
will happen there thank you very much
for reporting sierra will make sure to
get more updates as this case continues
jury selection was set to begin monday
in another wisconsin case the murder
trial for theodore edgeco the trial has
now been moved to january 18th we're
told the judge has coveted 19. edgcomb
is accused of killing immigration
attorney jason clearman last year in
milwaukee and what police are calling a
road rage incident edgecombe's defense
attorneys claim he acted in self-defense
they argued clearman's car which his
wife was driving at the time tried to
run edgecombe off the road while he was
on his bike the criminal complaint says
the two got into a fight and edgecombe
allegedly plunged clearman through his
open passenger side window in the video
you can then see the car follow edgecomb
onto a bridge that's when clearman got
out of the car and edgecombe shot him
edgecone claims clearman had a knife the
prosecution says he fled the state he
was arrested six months later in
kentucky edgecomb a black man is
receiving support from racial justice
activists as there are comparisons to
kyle rittenhouse who was white and was
acquitted while claiming self-defense
and nearby kenosha the 31 year old faced
his first degree reckless homicide
charges and felony bail jumping charges
newly unsealed documents reveal
convicted sex offender jeffrey epstein
paid one of his accusers half a million
dollars to settle lawsuit in 2009. this
comes ahead of a scheduled hearing
tuesday in the lawsuit virginia dufrese
filed against prince andrew last year
drew frey claims she was forced to have
sex with the duke of york when she was
younger than 18. but prince andrews
lawyers are expected to argue the 2009
agreement between drew frey and epstein
shields him from lawsuits since it
covers quote other potential defendants
prince anju has said he doesn't remember
meeting drewfrey despite a photo showing
them together he stepped back from royal
duties after an interview with the bbc
about his relationship with epstein
and more developments in the jeffrey
epstein circle as federal prosecutors
request a judge dismiss claims against
two manhattan jail guards who say they
falsified records about the night the
financier killed himself in august 2019
tovah noel and michael thomas were the
guards on duty while epstein was
awaiting trial for sex trafficking the
pair allegedly fell asleep and browsed
online instead of checking on epstein's
like they were supposed to throughout
the night the next morning he was found
hanging in his cell the medical examiner
ruled it a suicide both noel and thomas
say they lied to make it seem like they
were monitoring epstein federal
prosecutors say the two cooperated with
deferred prosecution agreements made
earlier this last year
last week elaine maxwell epstein's
former girlfriend was convicted of sex
trafficking among other charges for
recruiting and grooming young girls for
epstein to sexually abuse
still ahead on law and crime daily after
millions of signatures and increased
outcries rahel aguilera mudero's 110
year sentence is commuted with the help
of the governor but first could a
federal fraud trial that's been going on
for weeks be coming to an end we check
in on the elizabeth holmes case in
california as the jury deliberates
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury
[Music]
box welcome back to law and crime daily
as we head now to california where a
jury says they have reached a consensus
on some of the charges in the federal
fraud trial for businesswoman elizabeth
holmes
monday afternoon the jury came forward
with a note saying they couldn't come to
a unanimous decision on three of the 11
counts of fraud and conspiracy holmes is
charged with after reading part of the
initial instructions the judge sent the
jury back into the deliberation room
those charges stem from the downfall of
her blood testing startup company
theranos the business was once touted
that it would revolutionize blood
testing but prosecutors say holmes lied
to investors and patients about the
company's technology to generate hype
and raise hundreds of millions of
dollars in funding her defense argued
other leaders in the company were to
blame if convicted holmes faces 20 years
behind bars a fine of 250 000 plus
restitution for each fraud charge after
months of testimony from more than 32
witnesses holmes took the stand in her
own defense she testified about
emotional and sexual abuse from her
ex-boyfriend and former ceo of theranos
ramish sunivawani bowwani faces the same
charges as homes and is set to be tried
in february
like the home's jury criminal defense
attorney bernardo violina and terry
austin are back to discuss the case from
2021. terry the home jury has been able
to kind of i don't know choose when they
deliberate with the new year holiday
creating a large break any potential
appellate issues you see
you know there are three categories for
appellate issues first of all maybe
there was legal error or judicial
initial conduct or ineffective
assistance to counsel here the fact that
this jury was able to take these long
breaks they could have been exposed to
family and friends there could have been
some conversations they could have let
outside influences
affect their decisions so you know that
could very well be one ground for appeal
but if judge davila basically questioned
them when they came in made sure there
were no issues i think that will be all
right and there won't be a ground for
appeal here all right we'll see how that
plays out bernard the jury note sent
saying they can't reach a consensus of
three of the 11 charges what do you
think that means and what are the
possible outcomes
well what we do know since they haven't
been able to reach a decision as to
three of the counts is that they have a
verdict as to aid of the count so we
don't know whether it's guilty or not
guilty but we do know that two of the
counts refer to conspiracy to commit
white rock and then nine of the counts
have to deal with wire fraud itself but
dealing with different amounts of money
that was actually defrauded by these
victims so in terms of what's going to
happen i'm surprised that the prosecutor
nor the defense requested to actually
take that verdict and have them stop
deliberating we'll see how much longer
that the judge is going to allow them to
deliberate on this matter but my
projection is that they'll take the the
split verdict all right we'll see what
happens and when that split verdict will
come out
today
another day we'll see hopefully not
sometime in 2023 though uh switching now
to texas where a total of twenty
thousand dollars in reward money is now
being offered to catch a
fourteen-year-old accused of shooting
and killing three teenagers at a texaco
gas station a day after christmas a
fourth teenager was also injured in the
attack 33 year old richard acosta and
his 14 year old son abel elias acosta
are charged with capital murder police
say the 14 year old fired more than 20
shots into the store and got away with a
white got away in a white dodge ram
truck by his father according to police
richard turned himself in but the
younger acosta has been on the loose
since the shooting officials say the
shooting may have been retaliation
against one or more of the victims
coming up on law and crime daily a more
than 100 year sentence reduced for rahel
aguilera medeiros the truck driver
convicted of killing four people in a
colorado car crash plus the retrial of
an accused killer is delayed another day
as deante rosales murder trial will soon
be heard by a new jury in a florida
courtroom
[Music]
welcome back a big development in the
case of a truck driver sentenced to more
than a hundred years in prison for a
crash that killed four people his
sentence has been reduced law and crimes
angina levy is here with how it happened
brian rahel aguilera medeiros sentence
of 110 years in prison sparked outrage
in colorado and across the country but
now the governor of that state has
commuted his sentence to 10 years a
judge sentenced aguilera medeiros to 110
years in prison last month for the 2019
crash the judge said at the time that
state law required him to sentence
aguilera medeiros to consecutive
sentences a petition to reduce the
sentence garnered more than 5 million
signatures online
then in an unprecedented move
prosecutors asked the court to reduce
aguilera medeiros's sentence to between
20 and 30 years the judge in the case
was actually going to reconsider the
sentence at a hearing next week but late
last week governor jared polis granted
clemency commuting the sentence to 10
years now aguileras medeiros lawyer jim
colgan tells me that his client is
pleased by this result and is also
humbled by all of the report he
support rather that he has received from
the public but the family of bill bailey
one of the victims killed in that crash
called governor pulis a despicable human
being in an interview with a tv station
in denver because the governor made that
decision ahead of the hearing next week
brian
thanks andrew now let's bring in
criminal defense attorney bernardo
villalona and co-host terry austin to
discuss the tragedy on i-70 terry as you
hear from the victims families do you
think the governor made the right
decision
i do brian i mean this is a very
difficult case we know that these
victims have been heavily impacted and
he was going 85 miles per hour and the
question really is could he have avoided
this accident but he said that the
brakes failed there doesn't seem to be
any contention as far as that's
concerned and if it really is a true
accident then i think the amount of time
110 years is way too long and i think it
was the right decision even though the
timing might not be right to bring it
back down to something that is far more
reasonable for a case like this now bro
that's kind of focusing on the what your
thoughts on the how we got here do you
think gov the governor should have
stepped in before the judicial process
was done
i think it would have been different
difficult for the governors to step in
because it's unprecedented when you're
dealing with cases like this is the
prosecutor's office that takes leads so
for the governor to have stepped in
before there was a sentencing date it
would have been improper however in this
case i do see that it was proper for the
governor to step in because we're
dealing with a state that had a
mandatory sentencing that's how we got
to 110 years and it's only the position
of the governor who would have been able
to make any changes unless the
prosecutor would have dismissed some of
the counts which would have lessened the
mandatory minimums against him now and
jeanette with a 10-year sentence what's
the soonest uh aguilera moderates could
be released
well governor paulus bryan wrote in his
letter to aguilera medeiros that he
could actually be considered for release
come up for parole on december 30th of
2026. that would be exactly five years
from the date that his sentence was
commuted and jim colgan the attorney for
aguilera medeiros told me that there's
really no reason for him not to get that
parole because he doesn't have a
criminal record and he believes that he
will be a good prisoner
inside the prison system all right thank
you for that update and jeannette
when we come back a defendant who's been
in jail on murder charges for years will
have to wait another day jury selection
is delayed in the deontay resilies
retrial
[Music]
welcome back jerry selection is moved to
tuesday in the florida courtroom for a
man who's being retried for murder this
after delays with some of the state's
evidence
deonte razales is charged with
first-degree murder for allegedly
killing jill halliburton sue and leaving
her body in a bath in her bathtub in her
home in 2014. prosecutors allowed
razielas broke into sue's house to
burglarize it but discover she was home
razillus allegedly tied her up and
stabbed her more than 20 times the now
27 year old was on trial for murder in
late november and into early december
where the jury deliberated for five days
before coming back with a manslaughter
verdict but the judge declared a
mistrial after wonder disagreed with the
verdict rosellas also made headlines in
2016 after he escaped from the broward
county courthouse while awaiting a
hearing he managed to break free of his
shackles and striped jumpsuit before
getting away with the help of several
accomplices on monday as jury selection
was about to start whereas alice's
defense team filed several motions which
were denied by the judge including
moving to dismiss two charges on double
jeopardy grounds the state said since a
verdict wasn't previously reached double
jeopardy doesn't apply their request for
removing the death penalty as a possible
sentence was also denied
bernard do you agree with the state that
double jeopardy doesn't apply to the two
charges
the defense tried to get dismissed and
if so why
so in terms of whether double jeopardy
applies i don't i agree that double
jeopardy doesn't apply because you don't
have a verdict by
by a jury stating that whether he was
guilty or not guilty you ended up having
what i would call a mistrial because you
don't have a consensus as to the verdict
so the state would be entitled to retry
mr razillis again
now terry delays because of evidence
that kind of makes me uh raise my
eyebrow or so does that mean that we
should expect new information in this
retrial that we didn't see in the first
not necessarily brian i think that
they're just talking about maybe
scheduling of witnesses i mean the
mistrial was just declared on december
8th that was not that long ago and i
don't think that there's additional
evidence we know that there was dna
found on that belt and we know that
there was dna found on the knife at the
scene it could be that the defense is
looking to see whether or not that
cross-contamination dna has more
relevant information that they can
disclose to the jury this time around
but i definitely don't think that there
is a whole slew of evidence that they're
going to bring for this new trial they
just haven't had enough time now
bernardo in let's say like 20 seconds or
less i always ask people retrials who
has the advantage the prosecution or the
defense
so it says that the prosecution always
has the advantage because now they know
what the defense is going to go with so
now they can drain their case to be more
specific to try to contend any type of
allegations that the defense is going to
go with yeah i know many people
especially defense attorneys i'll put my
hand up for this one say the elements of
surprise is oftentimes the defense's
strongest uh weapon in the case with
that being gone in a retrial it's gonna
be interesting to see how this plays out
of course you think why didn't he take a
plea in between this uh
retrial mistrial whatever it may be well
bernard terry thank you very much for
your input and thank you for joining us
here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you